satine je commence sur ce sont je le dis
toi qu'à 16 ans est-ce que tu le qui
fout pas franchement je kiffe et
l'instru et génial l'accord est
clairement trop trop seul
[Musique]
cette souris en prennent
non
[Musique]
tous
à kaboul en plus ce sera avec moi je lis
dans la grande jarre yade et camille
camille lellouche qui nous pûmes jamais
comme un ouf de voir comment je quitte
cette personne et j'adore est tombé
merci je remercie mots je remercie mon
ex
tu m'as
alors comment ça se passe et prison m'a
dit surprise avec moi j'ai juste
accompagner parce que tu sais qu'on est
amis dans la vraie vie ouais c'est bien
jean rachid il est là on le voit pas
illégalement bien sûr et moi et donc
soutenir un jeu voilà c'est mon ami il
mérite tout ce qui lui arrive depuis
toujours c'est un génie je le dis tout
le temps pour lui c'est trop mais c'est
un auteur de deux de j l'humilité elle
est absolu et moi je suis fier d'avoir
fait un morceau avec avec cette personne
que je considère vraiment comme on
galère aujourd'hui bientôt jatoi 50
millions et on est bientôt à cet autre
million est un homme que j'aime quand
même content et je vais donc moi je vais
pas venir j'ai gardé ma veste au cas où
parce que comme tu es fou ou s'ils vont
le faire peut-être venir j'ai dit voilà
il faut absolument que je vienne pour
thème de ouf toi je te dis juste un truc
né montre auscitains virginie est le
retour à mon tour qui qui en france
aujourd'hui c'est faire de la scène com
hk jure être comédienne comme effet lui
mais je t'aime clk composé la musique
qui sont là aujourd'hui elle a un tube
de ouf qui s'appelle je remercie mon ex
qui cartonne partout et elle trop forte
sur un stack ses six essais mais sinon
le seul sur scène c'est une bombe
t aujourd'hui chez numéro un chinois
j'vous jure c'était très surpris je
m'attendais pas du tout à ça